this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base
a subscription website where you can
download thousands of medical
images and videos to use in lectures
courses
presentations professional training and
more for more information
click on the link in the description
a coronary angioplasty procedure is also
known as
percutaneous coronary intervention
the procedure is done on blood vessels
called coronary arteries
they supply your heart muscle with
oxygen
the goal is to restore blood flow if a
substance
called plaque has significantly narrowed
these vessels
to begin the procedure the doctor will
numb the skin
in your wrist a needle will be placed
through your skin
and into your radial artery next a
flexible guide wire will be
passed through the needle into your
artery then
the needle will be withdrawn it will be
exchanged for a small
flexible tube called a sheath this
permits access into your artery
you may feel pressure when the doctor
inserts the sheath
but you will not feel it moving inside
your artery
next the guide wire will be advanced up
to your heart
a flexible tube called a catheter will
be advanced over the wire to your
coronary arteries
the progress of the procedure will be
checked with an x-ray device
called a fluoroscope at this point your
doctor will remove the guidewire
then the doctor will move the tip of the
catheter just inside the coronary artery
to be examined
a special dye will be injected into the
artery this allows your doctor to view
it better with the fluoroscope
the dye will make any blockages in the
artery stand out
if a significant blockage is found your
doctor will insert a guide wire into the
artery
a balloon on the tip of the catheter
will be moved along the wire to the
blockage
when the balloon inflates it will expand
the artery
and improve the blood flow you may feel
some chest discomfort while this is
happening
after this your doctor will deflate and
remove the balloon
a wire mesh tube called a stent may be
placed in the treated area
the stent helps keep the coronary artery
open
your doctor will choose the proper size
stent which is compressed over a balloon
the stent will be moved into the artery
over the same guidewire
when the balloon is inflated the stent
will expand
and lock into place
after the balloon catheter is taken out
the stent will stay in place to hold the
artery open
at the end of the procedure the guide
wire will be removed
to find out more about coronary artery
angioplasty talk to your health care
provider